- One of these I do not like.
I don't know which one it is.
It really doesn't help that we
ate'em all at the same time.
(dramatic music)
- So we're at Rocket
Park in Houston, Texas.
And we're in space suits, so
I thought it would be cool
if we tried Astronaut Ice Cream.
- All right. Yeah.
- Let's do this.
(explosion)
- So the first one we're trying is
Chocolate Ice Cream with Chocolate Chips.
The presentation is not
the best on the inside.
They were kind of just like, "Here it is."
- Cheers.
- Oh wow.
- Mmm.
- You know the texture is exactly
like Lucky Charms marshmallows.
- Mmm.
- You want one more?
- Mmm. On a scale of
one rocket to 10 rocket,
how good was this one?
- I'd say at least seven.
- I'm a chocolate lover.
I'ma give this an eight.
I'ma take another bite.
The next one we're trying
is Ice Cream Sandwich.
Oh, it's cute.
- Oh yeah. They really got the look of the
Ice Cream Sandwich down.
Kind of has more of a toast texture.
- I think I like how cool
and refreshing ice cream is,
so it's just really weird.
- I'm gonna put that one at six rockets.
- I'ma give that one a five. Five rockets.
We got some freeze-dried Mint
Chocolate Chip Ice Cream.
Ooo la la.
(fantasy music)
(laughter)
- It's like taking a bite of air.
- Mint is supposed to hit
you in like a cool, old way.
It tastes like mint gum was hanging
in my mouth in my mouth for way too long.
I give this a two.
- I was gonna say one,
but I am still eating it,
so I'm gonna go with two.
- Kind of a Neapolitan-style ice cream.
- Neapolitan. All right.
Pretty excited about this one.
- I used to only eat the chocolate part,
'cause I didn't like anything else.
- Oh. How did everyone else
in the family feel about that?
- I was the unloved child.
- Oh.
- Strawberry first.
- All right.
- [Man] Hey, you should
really put one of each
in your mouth at the same time.
That's how people eat
Neapolitan ice cream.
- Thanks, random stranger.
- Sure.
- I like it.
- Do you?
- This is like that nice
kind of flavor of all
the ice creams just
kind of working as one,
in perfect harmony.
- I think the strawberry
is the one I don't like.
There's just like not
enough strawberry flavor,
and it's more just like
hard marshmallow flavor.
- I'ma give this a seven.
- Like combined, or one?
For the strawberry,
negative eight, to bring it
down to one out of 10.
- What does that equal?
- One.
- Okay.
- I'd eat this any time. Yeah.
We don't even have to be in space.
You can enjoy this anywhere.
- You know what, if we were in space,
we wouldn't have options.
We've learned something today.
Being an astronaut is very hard.
- Yeah.
- But ice cream can make it better.
- Unless it's mint.
- Or strawberry.
(dramatic music)